"Sorry you can't unring the
bell -- ringing app apparently"
Hey guys, Pete here. Well, the most fun thing
that we've been up to has now come to an end.
Today I'll be talking about Severance Season
1 Episode 9. The finale of the first season,
and I guess we shouldn't be surprised that this
was a cliffhanger. that they would end that way
one more time, but that is what happened. But,
there's also good news to go along with it. Apple
TV+ has greenlit season two. so we know that there
is more coming, but we're gonna have to wait for
a while to see what happens in the aftermath
of the innies waking up outside the office.
that is primarily what happened in the finale.
there's a lot of interesting stuff, we got some
answers to some big questions, and we got some
new ones and I'm gonna throw out a quick spoiler
warning. obviously if you haven't watched the
finale of the first season there's gonna be a ton
of crazy spoilers in this so that's your warning
and with that out of the way let's get into it.
the thing that worked for me about severance right
from the very beginning was the idea that having a
device inserted into your brain to separate your
work and personal lives sounds absolutely absurd
but at the same time all together possible. you
can have the thoughts "no one should ever do this"
and "some people would definitely do this" in your
head at the same time. just like you can have the
ideas "that was as thrilling, masterfully crafted,
intense, and enjoyable of an episode of television
that I can imagine" and "I can't believe I have
to wait for maybe a year or more to find out what
happens next" sharing space inside your head. the
premise sets up a lot of fascinating questions
chief among them is what kind of people
would voluntarily sign up for this procedure?
throughout the first season we saw some of the
motivations for the normal people in this process.
using Mark as the example he had tragedy in his
life he lost his wife and he thought that being
able to check out eight hours a day would help
him deal with that. Petey appeared to be similarly
motivated. the finale presented us with some
alternate motivations. of course the big twist
is that Helly R is really Helena Egan the daughter
of lumen's current ceo jmegan the motivation
there is to create some positive pr for their
family-run corporation and this controversial
program we didn't learn much about irv's initial
motivations but he does appear to be working
towards understanding and possibly exposing what's
happening on the severed floor so after you get
past who might get this procedure you can move on
to what happens to the severed employees in this
new life where they never leave the office who
do they become how much of their audi is still in
there and how are they different the revelation is
that because the any versions don't have the same
experiences and aren't in fact driven by their
audi's motivations things can go wrong in response
to her uncomfortable transition helly ends up
siding with her co-workers and if erv hadn't
fallen in love with bert he may have continued to
be a model employee indefinitely there might not
be enough coffee in the world for his audi to set
off that integration or whatever he was trying to
accomplish there but to recap what happened in the
episode it does pick up right where episode 8 left
off dylan is flipping the switch and activating
the innies outside the office in a great three-way
split screen shot you see irv helly and mark all
switch over at the same time in their different
locations initially the focus shifts to mark and
you hear that harmony is asking him if he's all
right remember his audi was telling her that he
was thinking of quitting the job she encouraged
him to do that she's trying to continue the
conversation saying that maybe he should talk to
his sister since it's a big decision he's somewhat
disoriented but he doesn't give away the game
from his perspective this is directly after he
followed ervin helly up in the elevator he should
be as prepared as he could be considering the
circumstances it's nice here that you can pick
up on the slight changes that adam scott employs
between how he portrays the two different versions
of mark because of that cobell senses something's
off but she has no reason to be suspicious
in his apartment irv wakes up to motorhead blaring
on the boom box holding a pallet knife in his hand
he sees the painting of the elevator that goes
down to the testing floor he looks around the
room and he sees that there are several completed
versions of this same painting sitting against the
walls heli wakes up at the gala and most people
expected that this was going to happen after the
last episode and the first voice you hear there is
familiar it's natalie's she also senses something
might be off and even asks her how many glasses
of champagne she's had they need her nimble and
you learn that she was talking to the board and
they're really grateful for this thing that she's
doing they run into gabby the senator's wife devin
met at the birthing center and this is where we
get the reveal of her full name helena egan so
at this point neither of the two of them that
are around other people are acting very natural
but again there's no reason for anyone to be
suspicious of them i should mention that there are
several shots of dylan cut throughout this entire
episode where he's stretching between the two
switches to keep them open this is not a position
that he'll be able to hold indefinitely we
understand that and it makes for a ticking clock
situation mark wanders around he almost gives
things up by asking his sister how's our baby
but she just sort of writes it off to this weird
brother and sister banner that we've seen them do
a little later he learns that it's his sister from
two of the guests that were at the no food dinner
party from episode one he meets rebecca who was
also there and then tries to start a conversation
with devin but then ricken announces that the
reading is about to begin this is something that
i was really looking forward to and i love the
look on his face when he sees that they're getting
ready to read his favorite book he's absolutely
odd whenever he sees rickon and eventually puts
it together that this is his brother-in-law when
he dedicates the reading to his daughter eleanor
annie mark is just completely lit up when this
reading begins and harmony leans over his shoulder
so that she can read along at the first break
he goes out to talk to rickon and tells him how
brilliant the book is he tells him that this book
opened the world up for him and that it changed
his life naturally ricken finds this strange but
at the same time he's thrilled to learn that mark
not only read the book but actually likes it so
it feeds right into his ego he asked if they're
friends and rickon tells him that he knows that
there's been tension between them because he feels
like he looks down on him for doing the severance
procedure but he understands that he had to deal
with gemma's passing in his own way he brings up
seeing a picture of the four of them together on
a hike but he's pulled away before he can show it
to him he goes again to look for his sister so he
can complete his mission tell somebody what's
going on and he gets stopped by harmony and
then as he's getting away from her he accidentally
calls her miss cobell which leads to her realizing
that something is definitely up devin is holding
the baby who's crying and she passes her off the
cobell so that she can go talk to mark alone it
cuts away just as he's about to reveal that he's
actually the innie version of mark irving meets
his dog radar then he looks through his apartment
where he comes across the foot locker inside he
finds things from his father's time in the navy
and beneath that he finds a trove of documents
about lumen and severance there's a newspaper
clipping about a severed worker suing for
information following an injury with a headline
that reads lumen needs to be held accountable
if you look closely you can make some of the
article out and it says that the employee lost
the sensation in one of his fingers where he could
have made a full recovery if they would have been
honest with him about what happened instead they
told him to go home and put a sav on it and now
he's suing trying to find out what really happened
there's a list of severed employees and he
finds bert's name and address on it there's
also a map he opens that up it has addresses
of known employees marked on it and he figures
out how to get from his apartment to where bert
lives he puts on his coat grabs his car keys and
gets inside to try to make his way over to see
bert at the gala gabby is talking about how much
having kids changes your life to helly and she
says she couldn't have done it without a little
help and she gives her a kind of smile where it
looks like there's an inside joke between them
and then she basically confirms that she's had
the procedure when she says that she can't believe
that there's people out there who would want to
outlaw severance her senator husband comes over
and says that the photo display was very moving
but he already knew how he would be voting it
becomes apparent that she's part of this campaign
to help change people's mind about the procedure
and it's all part of a bigger plan to make
legislation that would protect it he thanks
her and then he asks her to thank her father if
she sees him she does see the large photo displays
that are the centerpiece of the gala they say
helly a severed story their pictures of her and
her co-workers in mdr and these large rotating
light cubes she pauses at one with mark on it
which reminds us of this newfound connection
they have and then she watches an interview
with her audi in that she talks about her father
and you start to get the idea that he's probably
the current ceo james egan she's essentially doing
pr speak talking about how lumen is a big family
united under the same values as laid out by the
core principles she starts to look overwhelmed so
she goes into the bathroom to collect herself
and then her father is led in to talk to her
he is in fact jameegan he looks exactly like his
wax figure from the perpetuity wing and after he
compliments her on how nice she looks he asks if
she's still in pain this makes it sound like this
is the first time they've seen each other since
the suicide attempt he says that he cried in bed
when they told him what she did to him what that
innie did to him and there's noticeable disdain
in his voice when he says the word any he thanks
her for going through with the procedure and tells
her that the grandfather would cherish what she's
done referring to kyr and then he adds that one
day she'll sit with him at his revolving which i'm
sure is a term that we're going to be wondering
about until season two starts he asks if she
remembers when he brought home the first chip to
show her he refers to it as the prototype and says
that it had the blue and green lights back then
and that makes you think about the green and blue
badges and the way that those were reversed in the
paintings of the coup he says that he remembers
that she told him that it was so pretty and that
everyone in the whole world should get one
and now he says that they will they'll all
be keir's children natalie comes in to interrupt
them to say it's time for her to give her speech
left alone she pauses at the mirror and she begins
to recite the compunction statement that she had
to say when she was in the break room cobella has
left a party in her car she's driving recklessly
towards the lumen office trying to get milcheck
on the phone mark has made his confession to devin
he tells her that they need to get inspectors
to go and check out what's happening on the
severed floor she mentions that his audi has
been trying to figure out what they do at work
and he responds that he just wants to know why he
went through with the procedure and that leads to
her explaining that he lost his wife she explains
how he tried to go back to his job as a professor
but he wasn't able to because she was still in
his veins you know making everything hurt just
after we see harmony pass herb going the other
way she finally gets milcheck on the phone she
tells him that the otc has been activated and
that she just saw mark as his innie at the party
she believes that dylan is behind it and that they
were planning this all along she tells him to get
to the security office and stop dylan he takes off
sprinting down the hall but he can't get inside
the office when he gets there because of dylan's
belt devin tells mark that she thinks they need to
be careful about who they talk to because lumen
has their hands in so many pies she thinks the
right idea might be to contact journalists that
rickon knows while they're talking about that
he remembers to ask her why cobell was there he
explains that that's his boss and devin realizes
that it's who she knows as mrs selvig this freaks
her out because she knows she gave her baby to her
and now they can't find her the whole party starts
to look for her and at this point everything is
starting to come together helly's getting ready
to go on stage irv has pulled up outside bert's
house and milcheck continues to cut through his
belt while he tries to talk dylan down offering
him new perks ones that he says he's never even
heard about like paintball and coffee cozies
and dylan just says he wants to remember his son
being born at this milchek tells him he has two
others and promises to tell him their names if
he just opens the door harmony does arrive at the
gala she runs inside in such a hurry that her car
rolls away in the commotion and you see the valets
chasing after it inside natalie's preparing hallie
telling her to just stick with the talking points
use the line about how you see your innie as your
sister irving sees bert through his front window
and sees that he's with another man it looks like
they're together and they're packing up for a trip
they do find eleanor in her car seat in one of the
bedrooms and it's hilarious that this other guy
takes the credit for being the one who found her
on stage natalie is warming up the crowd and she's
talking about how there's been setbacks bumps
in the road but now they're on the verge of a
revolution a kind and empathetic revolution that
puts the human being in the center of industry
at the same time cobell grabs heli she asks
is it you and helly looks at her and says i'm
going to kill your company cobell responds your
friends are going to suffer mark will suffer
you'll be long gone but we'll keep them alive in
pain and of course this is something that we'll
be coming back to kelly's pulled away to go on
stage as she's coming out you see mark pick up
a photo from his wedding he recognizes mrs casey
irv gets out of his car and goes up to bert's door
millcheck continues to cut and heli introduces
herself saying my name is helly r i'm a ninny
and everything they've told you about severance is
a lie irv continues to pound on the door shouting
bert's name mark runs out of the room looking for
devin helly continues saying we're not happy we're
miserable they torture us down there milcheck
finally gets the door open and charges towards
dylan helly is pulled away tackled on stage by
natalie and mark shouts to devin she's alive just
as milcheck tackles dylan causing him to let go of
the switches you see mark switch back over to his
audi and the episode ends there and you have to
hope that they will understand that he was talking
about the picture with this whole eleanor gone
missing commotion happening at the same time of
course the baby's alive but that's not who he was
talking about so yeah this was a fantastic episode
of television to cap off a fantastic season they
layered the tension on top of itself and also
made a ton of references to things that happened
earlier to make it clear that you really need to
pay attention i think there probably would have
been a backlash if they hadn't announced season
two but as things stand it's a confident way to
end things keep those big questions out there keep
us thinking about the answers because there's a
lot of fun in that while also giving us enough to
know that it will all eventually lead to something
this is all propped up by terrific performances by
an amazing cast snappy writing deliberate pacing
genuinely funny moments and a strong vision in the
directing at the center of the story you've got
mark who's trying to become something he's lost
his partner and that's left him not knowing who he
is he made what to us doesn't appear to be a sound
decision but in the end it may lead him on the
journey he needs to go on in order to find himself
the surface level critique of the way we view
work and what we go through is enough to pull
you in and then where it really gets fun is that
the innies are basically children they're fully
formed adults that are influenced by things
the same way as you and me but they have zero
experience shaping them as individuals lumen is
a corporation that certainly has some cultish
undertones there's something going on with these
eagans even more so than the normal kind of thing
that happens at real corporations all the time
in our world and they're trying to mold these
people into model employees in light of that what
happened in the finale is basically a disaster
but based on everything we've seen there's
only two real problems that they might run into
mark talking to devin and then the spectacle of
what heli said the way the gala was set up it was
intended to put a positive spin on the severance
procedure so you would imagine they invited some
skeptical people there to witness this thing
and she did a pretty good job of tanking that
they are pretty powerful though so you have to
wonder if they would be able to keep it quiet
or at least minimize the impact of what
happened i thought it stood out that cobell was
confident in saying that they were going to
keep the innies alive in pain we know that audi
heli wouldn't be supportive of what her any did i
don't anticipate her changing her mind about that
and for the others my thoughts went to these other
protocols we saw like the clean slate which makes
you think there's a good chance that they could
just wipe their memories it feels like there's
a non-zero chance that the next time they all come
together at work they won't remember what happened
it's not easy to see where they would go from
there though a big part of what happened in this
first season is that mdr came together and formed
this bond as a team they were able to make it out
and see the real world if they make it so that
lumen has the ability to wipe their minds then
there almost has to be a situation where they
can do that all over again so right now i think
they'll all probably end up back there working
in mdr probably even heli and we'll see how the
experience has changed them we'll see the backlash
from lumen and how their managers respond and get
closer to understanding all the big mysteries
in the process i think what irv's up to became a
really interesting question during this finale and
of course we're all still wondering what's going
on with mark and gemma aka miss casey the way that
irv is drinking coffee to keep his innate tired
possibly trying to get him to fall asleep at work
and then also repeatedly painting the same image
of the testing floor which he really shouldn't
know about certainly makes you wonder he seems
to be working towards integrating the indian
audi by passing that information telling him
to go looking for this elevator the whole romance
with bert was one of the most fun things to watch
because of the situation they find themselves in
and it made for a sad reveal at the end but i'm
still thinking there's more to come from these two
i'm just not sure how the way things were left his
audi is going to be at the door when bert opens it
and perhaps since his name was on the map they'll
already know each other maybe he's already reached
out to some of these severed employees mark just
has to go looking for gemma what's going on with
her and that testing floor is a central mystery in
conjunction with the story of him finding himself
being the central character it all makes marx seem
special not just a harmony but possibly to the
egan's overall goal and that is an even bigger
question i suppose we're closer to understanding
and that we know that they want to make everyone
kiers children but what exactly does that mean
waffle parties for everyone get people to get the
chip not just for work but in the way that gabby's
using it and then flip the switch activate the
cure army i mean i guess we're gonna have to wait
and see i'll take some time and think about it all
and then i'll put out a couple more videos i know
i said i'd do that last week but i got covered
and i still haven't really recovered yet but there
is more severance content to come i think this is
a good place to leave this one i can't wait to
hear what you guys thought about the finale how
your ideas about the show have changed what your
theories are going into season two so make sure
you let me know all about them in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon